This video is only for people on the left.
If you are not from the left,
you can scroll oust.
You certainly feel
powerless and angry at the policy
current in France,
but you have power,
so please go vote in the European elections on nine/06.
Know that the extreme right
is leading the vote today.
There are a lot of people who from
in France,
about 1 in 2 people.
Super important
also because the right
European Union premium over French law.
So what is voted by the European Parliament
then it comes into our right.
I give you 1 small reminder of the votes
of the extreme right
in the European Parliament,
against the action plan
for equality between men and women,
against the resolution
on equal pay for women and men,
against the resolution on public discrimination,
hate speech towards LGBT people,
against the implementation of the minimum wage in Europe,
against the revaluation of health care personnel,
against pest reduction
and against the deterioration of thermal sieves,
against the resolution
which condemns the ban on abortion in Poland,
against the fight against abuse by multinational companies,
against the carbon tax,
which aims to tax
the import of products
extremely polluting,
against household support in the context of
of the ecological transition.
You did a lot, right?
And yet this is a non-exhaustive list.
Indeux-mille-vingt-quatre,
France, she,
will have 81 seats
out of seven hundred and twenty in the European Parliament.
I don't know if you realize,
but just huge,
there is only one round.
All the more important to vote
because there is not a single winner.
That is,
all parties
will get 1 certain number of seats
according to the percentage of votes.
It's proportional.
The RN must not have a majority
otherwise we are in trouble